hi guys I was going welcome to sniper
for co-op with Bob the mission of yeah
proven rejection visit those missiles
must be in full swing
[ __ ] the component I found couldn't have
been for any other purpose uh-huh you
remember those components we found Bob
the operations yeah no I looking for
that Allah I love love Gaara I'm gonna
go with brah I'm gonna give you a few
more tries to get that right I'm gonna
duck it looks like an H is what's wrong
I was like aha growl aha grow yes I
remember those component late if this
mafia 3 what's happening oh god I have
no idea especially human Mauro evil
kissing the Dons hand [ __ ] mafia are
involved huh huh oh the mafia helped win
World War 2 I didn't know that that's
nice and infamous Mobb nice huh
he thinks I can give is that why we let
them do all that organized crime orders
ah yes I'm gonna go with him yes
absolutely 100% yes oh yes so they're
saying we're meeting him does that mean
we're meeting him or were me I think
we're meeting oh god its third person oh
you didn't know that I didn't know that
yeah I mean when you get your gun out
and you look down the scope it'll be
first person but I wouldn't worry about
that right now I want to get my gun out
how do I get my gun out I think we can't
do it indoors so just hold on for a
little second while I figure out how to
let you guys in the nuts the only thing
I know about this game is nut shots yeah
I know we're gonna literally the only
reason I agreed to play it I understand
that I get that know if your friend
anything else right okay cool that's but
I mean it is great to see you or
whatever but when did the nut shots
happen I am saying I'm assuming soon
this guy this dinelli is the guy you
mean nothing to me without testicle
shots are exploding balls you know if it
means that much to you you can shoot my
nuts I mean that's how good of a friend
we are you would make that sacrifice for
me of course any day of the week
Nellie I appreciate that you can't fight
it just to be clear I need those yeah
all right
I call that or a end of this dude we
have each one amis we like I would like
that too what kind of voice acting is
that I know I feel like that's an
America gutter just like I'm in a de
bahía oh ah it's me
mafioso guy can't even tell if it's good
or not because it's just like it sounds
like it's in a different echo chamber
than we're in right now cobble okay I
mean I'm good look at South American
drug kingpin and not like an Italian
Judas oh yeah that's true like a
Colombian drug lord yeah I can see that
although maybe we're just being totally
offensive and this is like a really
authentic Italian guy and we're just not
totally didn't only know American
Italian yeah it turns out the Italian
accent I think is which it is actually
just Mario I just can't tell the
difference yeah I got you just compared
to that I reside Mario Luigi this guy
John Donatello
Salvatori damn man actually the more I
listen to it the more I think this might
be authentic and we're totally in the
wrong here
it doesn't sound funny enough so I don't
think it's a real Italian accent I'm not
laughing therefore it's not real if you
selling me pizza or what I don't think
this is real oh how am I supposed to
tell what would be battalion or not
there's not even Pizza hey hey say the
word lasagna that'll prove it come on
say it spaghetti
give me something we're going to get
restricted aren't we a restricted why
are you being of my channel is going to
be put into restricted mode I'm probably
how does Wow
what are we doing here there's no George
since any of this help now actually a
psychological horror sniper Nukem dawn I
don't know how to get out of your
goddamn house hey book hi Johnny
oh [ __ ] we get out of here what's with
this crazy Italian uh pappardelle
type house you got here oh here we go
you have to press R by this ledge
you know that oh of course yeah press
are by this what yeah wink
why do you have to press are that isn't
okay for that come on it's Italy oh let
them have either time it's not actually
ten feet away from that house where we
were just at now it's night first time
yeah hey dawn
who is sponsorship good morning German
boys we're supposed to kill hold on I
want to shoot me something good for
Americans right son yeah zoom is that
guy for shooting I'm gonna try joonyoung
get him win but he's got a resilient but
hey i got an infantry kill how do i
rifle kill no assists I shot at him I
mean you can call that exists and oh
look look these guns are like shooting
enormous rockets or whether like go
prone in this [ __ ] uh hold see I think
see yeah that's good yeah that's what
I'm talking about now this is what
snipers do uh-huh yeah okay I know about
snipers and I'm pretty sure this is what
we do I feel like it's back yet see
anyone yeah wheres my 3d vision oh here
we go
I'm gonna get this officer guy got him
in the I got him in the eye all right
you just do all the work I'll just watch
where are we getting shot for away k I
got this guy I got this guy which guy a
few that guy I'm looking at a guy that
guy he's I got an A for Terkel oh shoot
not to the left oh what's the word
I moved yeah he went away ow oh there's
a guy SuperDuper close where got in oh
oh oh that guy that guy looked like he
had a family I said another guy like to
the right or something you see a million
whizzing Apple all right so that little
B is this I feel like this is not rough
this is not realistic we're just
standing here just like ya know we're
literally lying thrown only presenting
our heads towards the enemy which is the
only way knock
hahaha like I show if I could see your
kills I feel like you're getting cooler
kills than me oh you can't see my
slow-mo kills I'm not I'm not even
getting slow-mo kills how do you do that
I think only if it's like actually a
good shot I'm dying
we're like shooting badly so maybe if we
shoot something goodly like that'll
definitely shooting badly so hey why am
I not wiping the strawberry jam off my
eyes and healing this is [ __ ]
oh hey I move what where'd you go buddy
Jim I jumped out of the right friend oh
that would have been good to know if
that was better to just get off that
rooftop Oh alrighty then man who the
hell is shooting it I'm gonna shoot you
- oh I got through the [ __ ] eye I did
I did get a slow-mo for a good I shot I
got him right in the eyeball
ok so there's like a quick slow-mo and
then there's a super slow-mo when you
get like an epically long shot
oh god I'm bleeding out are you bleeding
out what did you do I stopped to search
this dead body it's right there yeah oh
thanks buddy
sorry about that how do I get you up uh
niello for me a little bit and getting
yeah I got you I'm just gonna heal your
one leg that was that's what was hurting
right look that's really the part that
was most [ __ ] up so I appreciate you
focusing your attention there yeah I
don't want to call you a little [ __ ]
baby but maybe you know just having dear
I'm gonna bring this guy with a super
piece I don't know if it's gonna help
but it just seems like maybe we need
this ok wait I can hey why have you want
to see my new attack that I just
invented yeah sure I'm ready huh
I just bussed around the corner with the
dead body in my arm
he's shot well I throw your dead friend
at you watch this [ __ ] ready
wha ah hold on
you guys [ __ ] Sheeran I can fire with
that dead body think you got me man
armor look oh wow alright perhaps that
was not the sir yeah try a little bit
harder let's try let's try just a little
bit harder not a lot harder
just a little I was that was full
[ __ ] around mode for me so I'm super
sorry no I'm not didn't mean it what the
[ __ ]
so we're we flip to go oh [ __ ] I don't
know where we're supposed to go man I
think maybe I have med tacks how do I
use med techs that'd be awesome
I don't know H nope that ain't a few IQ
q if you hold Q you go up to your thing
oh hell hell yeah woah if you hold what
are you pressing the talk I pushy oh is
it on okay yeah I turned it on a little
it's me it's me echo of your friend I'm
coming to you I think hi we're gonna
heal yeah I want to heal how do I
actually use it I don't know I sort of
just equipped it and then stood still
for a second and then it sort of just
happened equip it alright oh [ __ ] yeah
headshot wait equip it I somehow control
I put a piece of tape on a grenade I
don't know what that's gonna do don't
worry I'll kill all these [ __ ] okay I
got eight bullets left are you kidding
me maybe shouldn't the most so much you
couldn't you can pick it we started over
okay I missed that much mmm how do I
heal you pick them up off the ground
four bullets I don't know how you heal
I'm not I'm just gonna ignore it okay
alright fine I'm not gonna go I don't I
don't honestly know what I did it just
sort of happened uh-huh okay I'm just
all I'm gonna do is I'm not gonna get
hit ever again
so what are we supposed to do we're
supposed to be killing a guy okay we
gotta kill Hitler pretty sure that's
what we're supposed to do I mean duh duh
I mean like like you know like right now
like have it we're just having a good
time yeah I mean eventually it's a long
road long road Hitler I share a big
circle with a question mark in it I
don't understand a mystery of life is in
that circle and we have to discover it
to discover ourselves because in the end
it's not about killing people it's about
discovering who we are
oh yeah that's pretty cool
alright cool I picked up another med kit
that I can't use I don't know man just
just you know just do stuff or whatever
I could not fine well I got I got this
guy I'm gonna call him mo Mo's coming
with us
oh good yeah are you gonna use my attack
they're gonna use it no I'd never used
mo for something like that he's my
friend
he's just a filthy German guy like
they're not that look what do we both
need one yeah okay see this is what I
was talking about by discovering your so
I was gonna I'm not going to name mine
because mine is a weapon of mass box
truck
well alright mo can do some damage too
but I'm not going to ask him to do that
if you look if you get in front of you
look backwards as we're walking with it
[Laughter]
I'm gonna go in here hang on we're super
lethal snipers didn't you know you can
kill anybody
are you wait here just hang on I got a
load this paper I think you gotta gate
Abbot there Abbot piece of paper ain't
looking too good
what's up Abbot you think Don is
knocking out his window at us just
carrying by because the guy that we're
supposed to kill is just like it's just
a guy guys I said they killed me
ah oh man I got an enum whatever my name
is yeah oh my god he killed mo oh god
these guys mean business
looks like this guy's [ __ ] carrying
dead bodies around these guys oh wow
[ __ ] dude Jimmy mo at least if we're
gonna throw a dead body have the
courtesy to throw it off you know for me
it's on the body's like it's a Jessica
scrudge is it removes autograph I can't
wait for you to see that ass is
literally on the on this pot right here
yeah but he's like he's like limp bent
over backward I'm gonna try to get a
twofer here all right ha I know that
MODOK gently to go to bed ever
so that was so tender you guys don't
have like a serious moment you know I do
I just care so much about mo heaven
nope that was a miss hang on sorry it's
pretty close here I'll cover you while
you're doing this don't
Thanks keep an eye out those Germans
could anywhere I got you well thank you
all right on my screen they're like in
each other a little bit obsessed thing
that's ever happened mine is doing
angelic pose off of the edge he's so
sweet I'm oh you good good motion to
kill all the guys what exactly is our oh
if you push tab it shows you stuff uh-oh
search officer holy i'm asserts this guy
hey Allister walked off the edge i
walked off the edge pity her i thought i
would grab the [ __ ] ladder and he was
just like diamond ago hey i've upgraded
up this guy his name is Hansell he's an
officer much more important than mo
walking in the street with one touchdown
folks at delhi would you keep this Oh
what intruder where you don't know that
don't worry I'm your I'm your friendly
officer Hansell stop shooting at me guys
they'll do this hey doing what are you
doing guys where you go friend I don't
know the guide out in there shooting at
us and [ __ ] oh no I saw Hansel he was
like everything's okay I'm gonna go home
now everything's my friend I'm so I'm so
I'm gonna look at the controls because
what the hell is happening right yeah
that's probably a good idea what are you
[ __ ] he'll I don't know I got my human
shield and these guys can't shoot for
[ __ ] so I think it could be I I'm not
using a controller I don't believe Matt
loops okay oh you're like oh you're like
dying
hopefully now - I'm leaning out are we
both really no you cover me nope I won't
refuse I will not like not in there
honorable what the control I don't
understand I don't understand either
Billy these these guns are hot
[Music]